françois bayrou bon on sait bien que
vous aimez beaucoup les animaux les
chevaux évidemment que vous connaissez
particulièrement bien déjà aussi les
chiens aussi les chats aussi beau alors
moi ce qui m'a frappé dans cette réponse
du président à paul s'est il faut
réconcilier faut réconcilier les
chasseurs et les défenseurs de la cause
animale il faut réconcilier on en a
parlé tout à l'heure ça n'a rien à voir
évidemment mais on parlait des
réconciliation des mémoires sur la
guerre d'algérie alors est ce que le
président veut être le président
réconciliateur
c'est une question très très importante
et très très profonde selon moi
la mission d'un président de la
république de n'importe quel président
de la république ça devrait être de
concilier réconcilier entretenir la
compréhension mutuelle entre français si
quelqu'un ne fait pas ça selon moi il
manque à sa mission ce n'est bien avec
ses vécu comme un diviseur comme
quelqu'un qui a enterré un contre les
hôtes il y là l'opposition le critique
pour cela et bien je crois que c'est une
c'est une erreur de jugement
ça n'est pas comme ça qu'il est ça n'est
pas comme ça qu'il est personnellement
il déteste les
entretenir des affrontements y compris
dans son camp ça rime il y en a ça
arrive assez souvent
et il a de sa mission l'idée que c'est
une mission qui va permettre aux
français que c'est le d'avoir des
raisons de vivre ensemble
c'est ça le le socle
parce que si vous laisser aller les
choses dans un pays qu est-ce qui
l'emportent
c'est la haine c'est la détestation
c'est la stigmatisation sait on cible
celui ci ou celle là depuis la cour de
récréation jusqu'aux enceinte politique
alors xavier bertrand que tu es sur ce
plateau à quelques temps disait mais en
fait il ne sait pas ce que pensent les
gens n'a jamais été élu local il ne
comprend pas ce que pensent les gens et
ils les monter les uns contre les autres
et bien ceci est une
blague mal intentionnés c'est un
candidat contre un candidat potentiel
oui c'est ça oui un président on verra
ce que ce que je sais pour l'avoir vu et
pour avoir comparé avec beaucoup
d'autres pour l'avoir vu de près de près
sans caméra de près avec des gens qui
n'appartiennent à aucun raison que
l'establishment aucune aucune force ou
puissance
ce que je sais c'est son regard son
attention et je vais dire quelque chose
sa gentillesse franches parce que il
s'échappe pas quand il ya des trucs à
dire ce que je trouve plutôt respectueux
vous voyez je m'aime je n'aime pas les
ce qui qui enrobe de sucre les gens
qu'ils ont en face d'eux en réalité les
méprise lui il méprise pas et je vous
dis ça
pas comme politique mais je vous dis ça
pour l'avoir vu j'atteste de ce que je
vois j'ai passé des des heures et des
heures et des heures
jusqu'à
la mi très avancés avec des élus locaux
de base de petits villages et leurs amis
à discuter de leurs problèmes de deux
des problèmes de la nature des problèmes
de l'élevage des problèmes ce ce qu'il
vient de dire
sur les sur les vêlages
canton mais bah voilà les animaux
mettent bas pendant la nuit d'hommes
politiques qui parlent de ces sujets-là
en sachant ce qu'ils disent
oui mais voilà ni quand même pour le
faire il y en a quelques-uns qui se sont
beaucoup lever la nuit pour le faire
mais ce que je disais juste un mot pour
finir sur ce côté portrait un peu
personnel il y en a aussi qui disent
qu'il est sans affect
qu'il
et de ce point de vue là un très beau
nomme de campagne parce qu'il a une
relation avec les gens forte mais en
même temps c'est quelqu'un aussi
totalement sans affect mais vous voyez
il ya il ya une contradiction absolue
dans ce que vous dites
je me prête je ne vous prête pas de le
dire
vous rapporter des propos on ne peut pas
avoir une relation forte avec les gens
campagne électorale sur nes en affecte
n'a connu des gens sans affect on peut
pas quand vous êtes
sur cette vague là à cet instant la
quête un instant de rencontre
tout ce qu'ils ont vécu
à ce niveau pourront vous le dire qui
est de rencontre quasi amoureuse avec
cette communauté humaine ces gens ces
foules interne sommes des hommes
politiques qui leur qui l'entourent ça a
l'air d'être le moment c'est même que
stuff castaner qu'il avait en tout cas
moi je vous parle de ce que de ce que je
vois quand vous êtes dans cet instant là
si vous êtes sans affect traitement
croyez pas que l'élection présidentielle
soit un truc facile médiatique de
plateaux de télé l'élection
présidentielle c'est la rencontre cher
hr peau contre peau
avec un être mystérieux qui est formé de
millions d'autres êtres mais qui existe
avec
un peuple qui a son inconscient sa
mémoire ses souvenirs des choses
profondes y compris ceux qui l'a oublié
mais qui est terriblement fort comme
pour vous et moi l'inconscient des
psychanalystes ont dit ça une fois pour
toute l'inconscience et c'est
extrêmement puissant et bien c'est la
même chose pour un peuple et s'il était
sans affect d'abord il aurait pas été
élu franchement et puis aujourd'hui n'en
serait pas là alors à un moment parce
que je vois revenir là dessus bien sûr
je vais vous demander quel comment est
ce qu'il peut nous présenter une
nouvelle histoire pour 2022 mais mais
d'abord je voulais finir sur le thème de
la réconciliation parce qu'il ya une
réconciliation qui a été tellement
inattendu tellement surprenante c'est
celle que vous avez eue avec bernard
tapie ok décès oui bien sûr oui je sais
bien sûr sont eux oui oui mais c'est
l'histoire très émouvante parce que vous
moi je me souviens bien quand même que
vous étiez parmi ceux qui avaient dit
que la sphère du crédit lyonnais était
une affaire d'état et qui avait mené la
bataille contre l'arbitrage
contre la décision nicolas sarkozy
contre l'arbitrage qu'il a qui l'amenait
à des années de combats judiciaires et
des années souffrance
alors d'abord juste pour l'histoire la
première phrase de la partie de livres
que j'ai écrits qui s'appelait à bulles
pouvoir qui était consacrée à l' affaire
tapie la première phrase c'est il n'y a
pas d'affaires tapie est une affaire
d'état de gouvernement et c'est tout à
fait autre chose et c'est sur ce plan
que je me suis battu mais laissons ça de
côté parce qu'en effet j'ai été
en pointe et là que bernard tapie dans
une confrontation
qu'il prenait pour lui et qui pour moi
était contre ces méthodes de
gouvernement les méthodes de
gouvernement qui avait amené cette
affaire donc ça elle ne nie pas les
faits qui ont été jugés puis tout ceci
est derrière nous mais puis il s'est
passé quelque chose d'absolument
inattendue
moi j'aime la vie parce qu'elles offrent
des coups de théâtre
incroyable et tout ce qu'on croit
impossible en réalité si vous regardez
bien c'est probablement possible
le jour où son cancer a été diagnostiqué
bernard tapie
m'a envoyé un message
aux canons
qui disait à peu près que c'est à cause
de deux mois
qu'il était malade
et je crois en effet que c'est possible
que les grands les grands affrontements
comme ça que les les affaires
judiciaires
atteignent si profondément est donc il
m'a il m'a écrit ça
et je m'apprêtais à lui répondre quand
arrive un deuxième message parce que en
réalité il avait envoyé copie du message
qu'il m'avait adressé un de ses amis je
sais pas qui c'est enfin si je cherche
je pourrais trouver et donc dans le cas
lisez regarde ce que je viens d'écrire à
ce fumier
alors j'ai reçu le deuxième message et
je lui ai répondu ceci qui m'est venu
spontanément je lui dis j'ai reçu votre
premier message je vous souhaite du
courage parce que c'est quelque chose
c'est un c'est un combat
aussi dur est peut-être plus dur qu
aucun de ceux que vous avez menées
jusqu'à maintenant mais je crois qu'on
peut se battre
quant au deuxième message ne l'est pas
lui
et
dans la minute le téléphone a sonné et
il m'a dit je me suis complètement
trompé sur vous je viens de le dire à
dominique sa femme de qui qui avec il
avait une telle proximité je viens de le
dire a dominé que je me suis trompé sur
ce type c'est pas du tout ce que je
croyais qu'il était et est ce que vous
accepteriez de déjeuner avec moi et donc
à partir de ce moment là s'est construit
cette relation paradoxale
mais ça dit aussi quelque chose de lui
d'aider des coups de passion des coûts
de
qu'ils
vivaient qu'il assumait et on a beaucoup
beaucoup parlé
par écrit et dans des rencontres dans
des déjeuners de la vie de la mort de
l'amour
de dieu de enfin toutes ces choses qu'on
rencontre dans ces moments
suprême est qui
et qui sont au fond plus importante que
les autres un jour il m'a écrit un truc
incroyable
l'a écrit
une heure de conversation avec vous pour
moi c'est plus important qu'une chine ue
est là et nous nous étions affronter
honnêtement avec bobby directement tient
de manière absolument enflammé voyez
c'était ça et c'était quelque chose
d'autre que je trouve pour moi
formidable c'était une bombe atomique
d'énergie messiaen et de fidélité aux
siens parce que à sa famille notamment
la bouriane et de parler hier voilà
bernard tapie confidences eu sur une
rencontre improbable étonnante je
reviens quelque chose que vous disiez
sur les l'affect la rencontre avec un
peuple on en est pas du tout là mais
quand vous voyez le sondage ifop pour
lci aujourd'hui pour tf1 lci aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron arrive en tête marine le
pen est au second tout l'état 18 mai
elle a beaucoup baissé et xavier
bertrand et devant eric zemmour mais
eric zemmour continue cette dynamique
qu'il a entamée depuis le la fin du mois
d'août yannick jadot est en tête de la
gauche juste suivi de près par mélenchon
il des lourds en bas de tableau à cette
heure ci dans ce sondage dans cette
configuration il ya un phénomène emo
vous croyez qu'ils rencontrent il n'est
pas candidat mais ce que vous croyez
qu'elle rencontre
il ya beaucoup de sujets politiques que
j'accepte de commenter d'analysé
et puis en a d'autres en face desquels
mon attitude est pas du tout la même
sujet politique c'est dans le cadre de
la démocratie classique
à eghezée mans n'est pas dans la
démocratie
ce que eric zemmour porte
propose aux français c'est du poison
c'est le pire des poisons
que un journaliste ou un responsable
politique puisse porter au contact d'un
peuple
on ne peut ne pas s'en relever de ce
genre de poison parce que à partir du
moment où vous vous mettez à considérer
les gens en fonction de leur origine
de leur religion
vous vous mêlez de vouloir interdire des
prénoms vous savez ce que c'est un
prénom j'avais des enfants vous savez ce
que c'est un prénom vous donner ce que
vous avez de plus de plus merveilleux de
plus pensez que vous êtes assez
expérimentés politiquement évidemment
pour comprendre pour voir qui se passe
quelque chose où vous dites je ne veux
pas où je n'aime pas non je crois que
c'est un samedi mais cela ce qui se
passe ce n'est pas comment il y a
comment il ya quand il ya des
circonstances où il faut être en
situation de refus faut être en
situation
inébranlable
ce qui est en jeu là dans cette
exacerbation des sentiments les plus
dangereux des remugles qui existent au
fond des sociétés l'islamo fondée sur du
lait râler les conférenciers du monde
mais ça vous épate vous moi c'est plus
compliqué oui mais enfin bon mettons
vous
génériques les journalistes ça les épate
les observateurs c'est les épate les
hommes politiques ça les ehpad parce que
les sondages les hommes politiques c'est
l'alpha et l'oméga c'est comme ça que
commence et que et que fini leurs
journées dans la considération des
sondages moi je ne suis pas dans cette
attitude là et je pense qu'il faut être
intraitable alors il faut être
il faut pas débattre avec nous pas
débattre avec le sucre comprendre non
pas des balles 6 et autres shows
d'accord dans l'attitude les gogos qui
sont épatés sont d'une certaine manière
des vaincus et moi je ne veux pas être
dans cette attitude là je ne suis pas
épaté je suis
profondément comme comme france est
profondément atteints quand je pense que
ils ont organisé une journée qui
s'appelle des conservateurs il conserve
pas ils détruisent
ils sont là ils sont là trahison même de
ce que la france est dense on savait ce
que c'est la france c'est une adhésion
c'est une adhésion à quoi c'est une
adhésion au fait qu' on a choisi de
vivre ensemble avec comme sommet des
valeurs la fraternité à 6 et les
craintes de renan est lui aussi les
sites bon bah il ne peut pas dans ainsi
à les hits aussi on s'arrête une criaq
une seconde c2c de l'histoire
philosophique
renom sa définition de la nation c'est
une définition de refus de la nation par
l'origine de la nation par la naissance
de la nation par le sang et il dit une
nation c'est des morts et des vivants et
des valeurs de vivant et il met
évidemment la fraternité au nombre de
ces valeurs là et donc ce qui est fait
la ctu ça n'est pas c'est une attitude
de
déstabilisation de ce que nous avons de
plus précieux on connaît vous et moi
zemmour eric zemmour depuis
longtemps depuis 30 ans la vue jeune
journaliste débutant en la en l'afrique
aujourd'hui risquent donc il sera
candidat vraisemblablement oui et du
coup j'ai envie de vous dire mais est ce
qu'ils se préparent emmanuel macron à
cette candidature là le sondage le donne
favori
il est au deuxième tour ils l'emportent
dans tous les cas
est-ce que premièrement il réfléchit à
azemmour en se disant tiens ça peut être
qu'est ce qui va se passer et puis bah
comment est-ce qui gère cette position
de favori savez je dors je raconte
jamais rien déranger bien mais ça non
mais mais
quand vous êtes un président de la
république digne de ce nom
vous avez à chaque instant vos antennes
déployées et ce sont des antennes ce
sont des antennes affective
vous avez donc il comprend haïssant
heroes
attention oui avec surtout quand on est
en campagne parce qu'on l'a vu non allez
oui
aussi comme tous les présidents qui sont
sortants oui il est tout à fait normal
qu'il aille à la rencontre des gens ou
alors parce qu'autrement le sujet du
débat que et les questions que vous me
poseriez c'est mais monsieur bayrou est
ce que vous trouvez pas que quand même
c'est tout à fait anormal qui reste
enfermé dans son palais sourd à ce qui
se passe il s'occupe pas des la vie des
gens et des problèmes klein hilare
d'anne lauvergeon il y en a beaucoup
d'argent mais on va revenir on va
revenir juste un mot de quelle façon il
y penser qu est-ce que comment est ce
qu'ils préparent bon évidemment je pense
à cette fameuse maison commune qui est
évoquée qui a été évoqué tout ce
week-end à avignon avec la république en
marche avec vous avec
pendant un dîner de la semaine dernière
à l'elysée avec jean castex avec gérald
darmanin avec christophe castaner et
avec edouard philippe donc c'est ça le
je dirais la contre-offensive ans
étaient des gens en un embryon de
réflexion qui avait déjà commencé depuis
quelques mois de nombreux mois mais
est-ce que ça c'est une réponse qui est
de dire dans le fond on est centraux ou
rassemble mais au milieu au centre de
tous les côtés et on aime on peut
essayer d'être majoritaires comme ça
alors vous dites c'est une réponse
immédiate quant à moi c'est une réponse
que j'ai porté dans la vie politique
française depuis 20 ans prépare mais là
je parle des manières accompagné l'armée
va vous voyez
l'élection présidentielle n'est pas le
seul sujet qui entraîne cette réflexion
vous voyez la désaffection des partis
politiques vous voyez l'explosion en
continu perpétuelle ça n'arrête pas
d'exploser de se détester d'être en
concurrence au lait en faire une
nouvelle vous voulez faire un nouveau
parti politique voulait en faire un
nouveau
autour des ego ça passe son temps à ça
la vie politique est là tout le monde
voit bien qu'il manque
un grand une grande formation politique
ou une grande organisation politique
comme vous voulez qu'ils soient pas
perpétuellement divisée en chapelles qui
passe pas son temps à se contredire ou
house en tout cas à être en en chicaya
les uns avec les autres ça fait quatre
ans et demi qu'on partage la
responsabilité de la majorité
parlementaire il n'y a pas eu une
dispute donc voulait et donc forme c'est
là peut prendre concrètement une
organisation politique dans laquelle on
sera chacun avec son histoire
chacun avec sa philosophie on n'aura pas
de mal parce que la philosophie est la
même ou à peu près où il sera très
facile pour les français d'entrée
de partager un engagement c'est à dire
en attendant voilà loin de choisir une
chapelle et qui se présentera sous une
unité de
dénomination de communication de marque
d'alpharma ni
démocratisation identité le parti est
commentée et parce qu'il est parti du
président le parti voit le grand
mouvement central dont la vie politique
française a besoin pour être équilibré
pour être plus à l'aise puis de madame
puis de la république en marche chacun
vient avec son histoire et égard de l
élévation les i c'est pas du tout j'ai
dix l'idée que je m'en fais c'est une
coopérative quand des des agriculteurs
veulent
conquérir des marchés ils se mettent
ensemble il faut une coopérative
personne ne vend sa ferme mais on
apporte à la coopération les mêmes
produits ont peur on apporte à la
coopérative toute sa production on
fabrique les produits ensemble et on les
vend sous la même marque
c'est déjà pas si mal donc est ce que
dans cette copa que vous ont ils une
demi phrase pour une raison très
importante c'est qu'on n'a pas la même
histoire on a probablement pas
d'enfermement mais on a les mêmes idées
et c'est les idées qui comptent les sk
dans cette coopérative ou mettez edouard
philippe qu'ils en sont partis à la fin
de la semaine et qui en fait la
promotion sur twitter dans une vie
d'alors sur twitter on va le voir dans
une vidéo qu'il a fait à avignon devant
la république en marche il y à cette
coopérative poursuit le s'ils le
souhaitent oui bien sûr c'est à lui de 2
de faire ce choix là tout de suite en
même temps que vous ou bien un peu plus
tard peut-être après pendant l'année on
va c'est lui qui va qui va répondre à
cette question
mais on aura des débats naturellement
c'est à dire vous n'êtes pas tout à fait
pour non non non non je pensais tout à
fait autre chose et les propositions
politiques qui vont qui vont être faites
sur les sujets économiques et sociaux on
aura des débats mais justement
edouard philippe il a dit attention
alerte rouge sur la dette et sur les
déficits moi je me souviens il y en a un
qui incarne la question de la dette
c'est vous oui à chaque à chaque
campagne électorale qui vous appliquez
votre fonds de commerce pas du tout
alors je je parlais de débats
économiques et sociaux ghana qui a
beaucoup agité les esprits ces derniers
temps c'est la proposition de retraite à
67 oui parce qu'il dit comme il faut de
l'argent comme on a une dette importante
comme on a un déficit important qu'à un
moment donné il faudra la rembourser une
des solution c'est d'augmenter l'âge de
départ à la retraite et yves à 64 65 67
ans 67 à la révision est pas du tout
celle là et je ne pourrais pas soutenir
une proposition comme celle là parce que
une proposition comme celle là ça
supposerait que tout le monde est égal
devant la retraite
et je peux vous dire quand vous quand
vous êtes dans la vraie vie
les les femmes qui travaillent dans les
ehpad qui on a levé des personnes âgées
avec le poids que ça représente les
efforts que ça représente et qui ont le
dos bousiller à 50 ans souvent vous les
mettez à l'art vous leur dites vous leur
dites excusez-nous excusez-nous c'est
dans dix sept ans maintenant la retraite
et j'y pense chaque fois que je passe
sur les trottoirs de paris on voit très
souvent vous savez ces personnes qui
bouchent les trous dans les trottoirs
avec du bitume fondu et qui la loche le
bitume comme ça vous allez leur dire 67
ans l'art la retraite face à l'aéro
savez ce que c'est injuste il une phrase
vous savez ce que c'est des gens que le
travail si profondément usé qu'il leur
reste peu d'espérance de vie eh bien je
ne serai pas celui qui dira ce genre de
choses et si j'ai tellement défendu la
retraite à points dans ma vie c'est
parce que la retraite à points ça
permettait de traiter différemment les
situations professionnelles différentes
des gens qui avaient la possibilité de
poursuivre et de continuer kahn avait
envie qu'un navet l'énergie et cela il
faut leur offrir et la favoriser mon
avis mais les gens qui sont dans cette
usure là je ne vais pas moi les regarder
en dix ans excusez nous
vous allez faire 50 plus un jeune je ne
ferai ne change rien sur la retraite
aujourd'hui parce que la fois la réforme
la retraite à points elle était passée à
l'assemblée nationale elle a été mis
sous le boisseau à cause de duke aux
villes on n'en parle plus ou alors vous
pensez qu'on peut la remettre sur sur
l'établi moi je suis la présidentielle
je pense que c'était une bonne idée je
pense que d'ailleurs de grandes
organisations syndicales la partager je
pense qu'on l'a traitée de manière
beaucoup trop con haletant refaire une
d'ici là la présidentielle d'ici
l'élection plus rien françois on ne fait
plus rien sur la retraite d'ici
l'élection présidentielle ça n'est pas
de rien faire je pense que la retraite
sera un des sujets importants de
l'élection présidentielle et qu'il
faudra que chacun dise ces principes en
tout cas pour moi ce
ça ne peut pas être cette atteinte au
contrat social du pays attend le contrat
social et pays vous propose vous disent
que dit edouard philippe est une
atteinte au contrat social ne mettez pas
en cours en affrontement c'est pas mon
but mon but est de dire que oui on peut
rétablir les équilibres et si ça vous
dit je vous dirai pourquoi je le pense
oui on peut faire que désormais
on est des comptes sociaux des des
réformes importantes mais que ça n'est
pas en détruisant le contrat social
qu'on va y arriver ça je suis c'est
j'espère que vous sentez que c'est
toutes mes fibres qui disent ça mais
alors pourquoi on peut y arriver je vais
vous dire sur la dette
pourquoi est-ce que la dette
d'aujourd'hui n'est pas la date d'hier
parce qu'aujourd'hui on emprunte à 0
pour ce taux sont très bas mais ils
peuvent remonter non oui mais tant
qu'ils sont bas ça veut dire que dès
l'instant que vous avez une croissance
qui est plus haute que les taux
d'intérêt bas au fond vous gagnez de
l'argent et vous équiper le pays et la
dette n'est pas la même selon que à
l'époque où je me battais elle devait
être deux de 4 à 5 % les taux les taux
de 21% et la croissance était à 1 ça
veut dire que plus vous alourdissent y
ait plus vous empruntiez plus vous
alourdi si l'avenir je finis je finis
quand même si raiders fip en un mot vous
iriez wa aura la semaine prochaine parce
qu'il a invité tout le monde à y aller
je pense que je pense qu'il est il est
bien et bon que chacun vive ces
aventures où ces entreprises moi je je
je ne je ne suis pas pour le pour le
mélange des genres mais bon ce que je
sens quand même c'est que si emmanuel
macron souhaite cette fameuse maison
commune d'edouard philippe françois
bayrou ce sera compliqué non vos frais
ce qu'il faut pour y arriver oui vous
discuterez vous demanderai que bas par
exemple dans les points qui vous
rassemblerait y aurait pas cette
retraite à 67 ans en tout cas moi je ne
ga après bon là je ne voterai jamais ça
oui mais bon c'est certainement un peu
plus complexe avec de la pénibilité et
d'autres données on peut pas penser que
c'est 67 ans comme ça du jour au
lendemain sauf que l'espace et ses cinq
ans de plus alors il ya cinq ans de plus
d'ailleurs les gens partent pas à 62 ans
ils partent à 63 ans rezaï quelque chose
comme ça on peut tout à fait allonger on
peut encourager à langer on peut
encourager les gens à rester au travail
on peut en peul et on peut les aider
à ce qu'ils gagnent plus s'ils
choisissent de rester ça je crois qu'on
peut le faire
mais pas de date mais traîne pas de
panache couperet le fond et que on ne
peut pas traiter de la même manière des
situations aussi différentes et que
lorsque quelqu'un est usé c'est lui
manquer de respect que de dire que qu'on
va aller jusque jusqu'à 67 ans et
pourquoi pas encore plus loin il ya des
pays qu'ils font on se sentait pas
l'allemagne ce n'est pas la france deux
questions bref pour finir aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron annoncé qu'il réfléchit
on a appris que le président de la
république à voulait développer la
technologie des petits réacteur
modulaire les small ball au lactose qui
sont méconnus en france mais qui existe
en chine qui travaillent enfin qui sont
préparés en grande bretagne sont dans
d'autres pays et que emmanuel macron
juste là plein de promesses qu'est ce
que vous en pensez c'est est-ce que
c'est pas contradictoire avec la
réduction de la part du nucléaire à 50%
d'ici 2035 qui était son engagement de
2018 le
première question le nucléaire est il
indispensable ou pas et comme vous savez
vous y faisait allusion j'ai publié une
note
d'un plan sur cette question et dont et
dont la conclusion est sans ambiguïté si
on veut tenir notre promesse
d'avoir
de l'énergie sans émissions de gaz à
effet de serre il n'y a aucune
possibilité de le faire sans nucléaire
on peut aller vers une augmentation du
renouvelable ça va faire débat parce que
l'éolien ça fait débat et que le
photovoltaïque ce serait des hectares et
des milliers d'hectares recouvert par
des panneaux photovoltaïques
ce qui est aussi une artificialisation
des sols
donc il ya des il ya des débats il ya
des questions de réseaux comment on va
chercher cette énergie là mais en tout
état de cause il ya une certitude c'est
que cette énergie renouvelable
elle est intermittente vous en avez s'il
ya du solaire ou s'il ya du vent donc le
nucléaire vous serez réponse pénale
macro sera le un président qui défendra
le nuc les cours comme ça vous lui
demanderez à dakar il est ce que je
pensais
ce que je veux et ce que je conclus des
études je disais cette énergie
renouvelable elle est intermittente et
donc pour la compenser dans les moments
où il ya ni soleil ni vent alors il faut
une énergie qu'on appelle pilotable est
la seule sans émissions de gaz à effet
de serre c'est le nucléaire ce que les
allemands ont fait est une je ne veux
pas me fâcher avec
le gouvernement allemand est une
trahison de cet esprit parce qu'ils ont
remplacé le nucléaire qu'ils ont
supprimée par du charbon c'est à dire la
pire et du gaz des énergies polluantes
et du gaz russe suivez mon regard a donc
et donc il ya là quelque chose qui est
une grande question nationale en plus
c'est nous qui avons la compétence
s'étend à l'est de la france si parce
que le ce est adaptable on a choisi à
tort ou à raison un mot à mot jc gros
réacteurs les ep air avec les
difficultés que l'on sait
les petits et moyens réacteurs n'ont pas
ces inconvénients la dernière question
de magna une manifestation appelle la
cgt notamment pour les salaires contre
la réforme des retraites
contre la réforme l'assurance chômage
qu'est ce que vous dites ceux qui vont
manifester
c'est un c'est un réflexe d'abord tout
le monde a le droit de manifester mais
vous voyez bien que c'est
perpétuellement les mêmes
les mêmes slogans et moi je crois qu'il
faut profondément renouvelé le modèle
comment produites ont plus et mieux
comment réussit-on à créer des richesses
qui permettront de les répartir beaucoup
mieux que nous faisons vous en
connaissez beaucoup de pays qui ont
l'école gratuite la santé gratuite
les secours enfin le la solidarité au
moment du chômage systématiques qui ont
aidé chaque restaurateur chaque bistrot
français chaque petit artisan au moment
de cet ep d'aimer de cette épidémie et
de cette pandémie là vous en connaissez
beaucoup de ces pays et si vous regardez
les autres alors vous mesurerez que en
raison de la politique qui a été suivie
en france à repart très vite chez les
autres - dernière regarder ce qui se
passe en grande-bretagne avec le
brésilien sur juste une dérogation qui
est comment il peut faire à masnières
macron face aux radicalité presque 45 %
dans les sondages à droite des discours
chez les écologistes finalement qui a
été dépassé par yannick jadot mais enfin
très radicaux comment est-ce qu'ils ont
regarde comment elle qui tient ce qu'il
peut s'imposer face à la radicalité et à
la demande de radicalité sans doute en
amont on dit ça mais je ne partage pas
tout à fait mais ce n'est pas important
trois choses 1 la sensibilité
je peux attester parce que je le vois
quelqu'un de sensible et deux et trois
parce que ces deux mots en même temps il
faut être passionnément équilibré
passionnément c'est à dire qu'il faut
accepter les motions acceptées
l'engagement
accepter le les mots qui est qui
rassemble et est profondément équilibré
sur le fond parce qu'un pays comme le
nôtre dans des tempêtes comme celle
qu'il traverse a besoin d'avoir à sa
tête pour l'incarner quelqu'un qui soit
profondément équilibre est profondément
enracinée et profondément équilibre
merci beaucoup merci d'être venu sur
notre plateau dans un instant notre
débat d'opinion et je pose cette
question comment est-ce que manial
macron peut exister propos ep avoir une
nouvelle offre en 2022 face aux
radicalité à tout